[Music]
so you guys might have may or may not
have already seen this recipe on the
tasty Channel a couple of times I did it
behind the scenes of it yeah but I
really want to give you guys more
instructions and more of a story on how
to make this happen so the the
inspiration for this recipe comes from a
lot of New York restaurants were serving
it at the time it was pretty popular as
all of our Instagram and I was like man
I want to figure out how to do that for
this recipe you actually do not want to
use milk chocolate you want to use good
chocolate because you want it to be firm
you want it to be snappy you don't want
any of those extra sugars or other
things they put into candy bar that can
help kind of make the ball of a soft so
you really want to get nice chocolate
for this you want to melt your chocolate
but you do not want to over heat it
it'll cause it to coagulate so the most
important thing is that you need to find
the right containers or molds for the
recipe I use refillable ornaments that I
just got online you can find them on
Amazon basically they're these clear
plastic ball ornaments and depending on
how big you want the chocolate ball to
be it can be anywhere from four inches
in diameter to around eight inches you
really just you know need to figure out
what size you're gonna make and where
you're making it for that's probably the
most important thing and make sure you
get multiple because you're gonna maybe
crack some of the balls and then the
trick is to pour that amount of
chocolate into the ornament close it
really really really tight and you
really just want to like hold it impress
it so you do not let any of the
chocolate escape from the edges and just
slowly rotate it but you also you don't
want to move too slow sometimes what
happens is that if you rotate it and it
doesn't coat the whole ball it'll cool
down before and even coats the whole
thing and this is kind of hard so you
might just be like kind of doing this
weird you know ballerina dance where you
hold it look at it you know if you watch
the behind tasty I'd do this like three
hundred times
[Music]
so you kind of do that and watch it and
kind of tap it a little bit to get it
into the right spots after that they go
in the freezer and when they go in the
freezer you want to make sure that
they're level that they won't just roll
around everywhere and every like two
minutes or so until they're set you want
to actually check them make like I don't
seem like like you know four to six of
the chocolate balls put them in the
freezer expect some of them to break
because you really just need one and the
key to opening it is to really just make
sure that first you use your hands to
kind of hold it and warm warm it a
little bit so you kind of see like this
huge thing sometimes it'll crack
sometimes it will it really is a game of
luck
you know we're putting it on a heated
sort of pull to kind of rub so that's
the chocolate melts and you kind of get
this hole for it to sit and stand on to
fill it with anything you want after
that kind of put whatever it is on the
plate the key here is to keep the plate
the ball and anything cold so if using
ice cream keep it in the freezer until
the last second it using berries keep
them in the fridge if you're using a
brownie or a cake also keep it in the
freezer
keep your plate in the freezer you do
not want the ball to melt before
anything happens once you take that out
you kind of assemble one brownie or a
cake kind of put some berries around it
I like strawberries I like blueberries
you can fill it with whatever you want
honestly and you kind of put the ice
cream scoop on top of that and then you
put the ball I kind of want to snuggle
it over the sides if it's not fitting
you can either you know shave off some
more chocolate take out some of the
berries you just want to make sure that
when the ball is on the plate it looks
like nothing is underneath it it's just
a chocolate ball on a plate because
that's the surprise don't worry if
there's like little cracks between the
plate and the ball itself just run a
ring of berries around it it covers up
most of the problems that's what I
pretty much did and that is your
chocolate ball that is almost ready to
serve the last and final bit is going to
be the really hot ganache that kind of
goes on it and turns it from chocolate
ball to magic chocolate ball so the
chocolate ganache is just even parts
milk and cream you are pretty much ready
to serve so what you'll do is you'll
serve the dessert to whoever you're
making it for import in a circular
motion over the top and then
boom that's it from there you got money
Rand everywhere horns fanfares playing
what actually happens is that the
chocolate is going to melt the ball and
cause a waterfall effect where first
it'll make a little bit of a hole where
it first melts and then the entire thing
should theoretically crumble and
collapse in a really beautiful melty way
and the walls will fall away revealing
every single beautiful thing that you
put inside
hopefully it's colorful berries with ice
cream and cake maybe it's a wedding ring
I don't know is that how I'm gonna
propose maybe don't worry about it if my
future fiance is watching out there I
should probably change up the method huh
five layer brownie cheesecake was
probably one of my greatest
architectural feats if I would say so
myself I was actually studying
engineering in college not really a good
student to be honest but one thing that
I definitely needed pick up was the
ability of how to approach a problem and
how to look at it from certain angles
especially when things don't exist a lot
of times we are asked to do hypothetical
questions like if you wanted to
accomplish this how would you go about
choosing it and I learned that the
easiest way is to break down the problem
into its parts and kind of almost work
backwards cookie dough Oreos and
brownies are very common combination and
I wanted to take that further I really
wanted to turn the flavor profile of
like a just triple stack drowning into
something else I wanted to turn it into
more of like this spectacle dessert that
you could really Wow everybody at a
party with and I just absolutely love
layers and clean layers so that was
something that I set out to do was to
turn a triple-decker brownie into a
cheesecake the challenge with this
recipe is that all of these elements all
bake at different times different
temperatures and have different
thicknesses I kind of wanted to go after
your vibe of when you go to Cheesecake
Factory and they set down this slice of
this beautifully cut and assemble
cheesecake I really didn't know how this
was gonna go until I made it and I had
to do a lot of replanting and thinking
and being able to try to predict how the
food would behave in a way that I had
never done before I was hoping that the
brownie batter would not get dry I guess
that the cream cheese and the mixture
would give the brownie moisture it was
really gratifying to pull something like
this off especially when you have never
really done this before
I
yes I feel really happy relieved that it
actually worked after the brownie and
cheesecake were set that's when I put
the Oreos and the cookie dough on top I
don't try to do recipes a lot of times
because I think I really enjoy the
challenge of getting it right on the
first to the second try kind of
nerve-wracking to cut it open because
you really don't know how it's gonna
turn out until you actually slice it
open into the layers and to my luck it
really worked out well I was able to see
all four elements in their entirety I
love to spend time just thinking about
the food and really just trying to guess
and predict how food is going to behave
and sometimes I really just sit down and
write things down and try to map out our
draw out how certain food to look before
and after and so for this one I thought
about it a lot and made some decisions
and that's the sort of approach that I
like to take because there's something
really cool about trying something
that's completely new and then somehow
landing it on the first try so in my
video I combined brownies Oreos cookie
dough and cheesecake what combination of
desserts do you want me to attend next
[Music]
I try to come up with an idea for a
recipe what I really want to do is be
able to make people go like wow and
really show them something that they are
familiar with but maybe in a new way or
maybe something that is new to them but
in a familiar way it's always about
taking an element of something that
people know twisting into making it cool
or making it different combining with
other things and result it's doing
people go wow that's sort of usually the
approach I take when I want to really
showcase food to people in a cool way so
for the eight deserts in one sheet pan
it kind of came from a time where it was
the holidays I had seen a lot of videos
kind of pop up around like you know
desserts and baking and pie and Food
Network actually released this one video
that was pretty cool it was like four
pies baked in the same sheet pan and to
myself I was like wow like that's really
smart but can I take it even a little
further I know that pie is just one
dessert there are a lot of desserts out
there and a lot of baked goods that
people like to eat my hunch was that
around you know Christmas time around
the holidays usually at these Publix or
parties there would be a wide spread of
desserts you know Ranger cookies -
brownies - cheese cakes - pies I think
this crazy idea came about because in my
head I was like man what happens if you
just kind of put all those desserts
together like is there a way to take
every single dessert that everybody
loves and turn it into just one thing I
think that's kind of how the idea was
born is I basically thought of what can
I use to serve this giant dessert and
how do I make sure that everybody gets a
piece they want because sometimes when
you bring a dessert to a party not
everybody likes brownies not everybody
likes cheesecakes but is there a way to
make sure that no matter who you are at
the party you're gonna have one piece
that's gonna speak to you and that's how
I've sort of designed this eight
desserts in one sheet pan I wanted to
sort of build it in a way where if you
cut it in the precise manner you would
end up with just like a bunch of
different flavors you wouldn't really
cut it just along where the flavors met
but you'd be able to get pieces or bars
that would have two flavors three
flavors and the golden crown is when you
get that piece with all four flavors in
them the challenge with designing this
was that but no matter what piece you
get the flavor should still go together
so you kind of have to play this weird
like math mix-and-match game of like do
these two flavors go together
okay this goes together with this and
this must be next to here it was a lot
of mean or drawing things on a piece of
paper and crumpling it up like you do in
the movies and throwing it in the trash
can kind of restarting you after a lot
of trial and error I managed to get a
certain layout of which deserts should
go to which area in the pan so that no
matter which piece you got would always
taste great I'm super super proud of
this dish and I'd love if you would all
make it this year a lot of people are
intimidated by it and aren't sure if all
the desserts would bake together but
actually I was able to make it on my
first try and I really think you could
too and just really customize it how you
want if you do make it hit me up slide
in my DMS throw me a little pic oh god
it sounds so weird if you do end up
making it I want to see how you
customize it hit me up send me a DM show
me what you got oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you